y
qué estás haciendo a los 14m
yo un día a los 14 años estaba en un
centro comercial pagando el boleto del
estacionamiento cuando de pronto se me
acerca un chavo y me dice que si quiere
ser modelo o que si soy moderno yo en
ese momento me quedé el drone total
jamás había pensado en algo así se me
acerca me da una tarjeta de su agencia y
me quedo yo modelo la niña que se la
vive en pance en proxy que saben más de
cuerpos y de cocina que nada con moda
la verdad es que en mi vida había
pensado en ser modelo ni siquiera lo
había considerado pero soy alta chance y
con eso basta
después de eso me metí a una agencia de
modelaje en guadalajara unos cursos que
iban los sábados para que en palabras
del mundo paz se me quitara la duda
empecé a trabajar con esa agencia y
empecé a hacer trabajos pequeños con
escuelas que realmente hacía pues más
que nada por la inversión y por hobby
después al poco tiempo empecé a trabajar
con cosas un poquito más grandes a nivel
nacional con marcas ya diseñadores más
grandes más reconocidos en méxico
fashion méxico y campañas más
reconocidas a nivel nacional el 25
cumple 16 años y viajó por primera vez a
la ciudad de nueva york la verdad es que
yo viaje sin esperar nada para mí fue
común nunca ha sido nueva york vas a
viajar a nueva york por primera vez con
tu mamá la que más da
vamos viajo y hago uno de los desfiles
más importantes de la semana de la moda
de nueva york como exclusiva el desfile
de prensa
de ahí me vuelan a milán y cierro el
desfile de prado de ahí todo empezó de
tono mi carrera cierro el desfile de
prada y empiezan a volar cosas de medios
revistas periódicos desfiles como chanel
prada miu miu manchegos sangran todos
los desfiles más grandes que se puedan
imaginar que el sueño no la verdad es
que para mí era un sueño sinceramente no
les puede decir que aunque yo había
pensado lo que yo había considerado
porque no pero el sueño que yo había
considerado pero una vez que les estaba
midiendo me di cuenta que era un sueño
que si quería
era una cosa increíble estaba viviendo
una de los momentos más increíbles de mi
vida estaba aprendiendo cosas increíbles
estaba aprendiendo de las personas que
yo considero más creativas del mundo yo
siempre digo que las personas más
creativas del mundo están dentro de la
industria de la moda estaba viajando
haciendo amigos de todo el mundo
conociendo culturas del todo en alto
estaba viviendo tiempo en la escuela lo
cual obviamente no lo hizo lo más fácil
porque yo soy profeso para aplicar en la
escuela y para mí la escuela siempre fue
mi prioridad es básicamente no existía
en mi vida social mi vida familiar ni
iban nada mi vida básicamente consistía
en trabajar viajar y ya tutorías viajar
trabajar y ya y la verdad es que no me
importaba porque algo que yo quería
estar haciendo yo estaba cumpliendo mis
sueños mis metas y mis objetivos
llega el año 2019 el año que tanto tanto
tanto estaba esperando este año en el
que por fin me grabó de la prepa el año
me que al fin me voy a poder dedicar a
una sola cosa al modelaje ay qué tanto
estoy esperando y que tanto estuve
esperando dedicarme sólo a esto dejar
tantas cosas de mi mente y desde
finalmente enfocarme en esta cosa en mi
carrera en crecer la grande estaba lista
para mudarme a la gran ciudad de nueva
york para dedicarme a crecer como modelo
profesional al dedicarle todo el tiempo
las ganas y mi esfuerzo para crecer más
y más con mi carrera estaba consciente
de que no iba a ser fácil pero estaba
dispuesta a sacrificar muchas de las
cosas para llegar a lograr mis objetivos
me mudo a nueva york con una de las
agencias que estaba en ese momento que
es una de las agencias más reconocidas a
nivel internacional y al poco tiempo del
que llegó a la gran ciudad me dice me
llaman a la agencia y me dicen mariana
no
tienen que bajar de peso
sinceramente para mí fue como un golpe
que no estaba esperable para una niña 19
años
que nunca espera escuchar eso es un
vuelve muy duro
mariana tiene que bajar de peso
pero si el doctor me dice que yo hago
que estoy en un peso bajo para mi
estatura pero si ya no tengo 14 años
tengo 19 no pueden esperar que tenga el
cuerpo que tenía a los 14 años a los 19
estoy cambiando ya no soy una niña estoy
cambiando mi cuerpo está cambiando me
estoy convirtiendo en una mujer
soy una persona sana soy una persona
delgada pero mi cuerpo está cambiando
marianas y nos exactamente qué es lo que
desayuna qué es lo que come qué es lo
que cenas mañana que vemos en una semana
a ver qué tanto has bajado de verdad se
los juro que ese sentimiento que tuve yo
ese día
sentimiento de que mi percepción de mí
de mi cuerpo de mi vida de mis
preocupaciones cambiaron en el espejo
instantáneamente
de que
un bar con centímetros menos en el
espacio era lo más importante en mi vida
porque esa era una de las pocas veces en
la que menos eran más porque ese
centímetro menos de cadera le iba a dar
ese trabajo más te va a dar esa
importancia martín a dar esa
felicitación imaginen de eso imagínense
es la preocupación para iría de 19 años
que te acabas de jugar esta ciudad a
cumplir tus sueños y que te digan que
tienes que bajar de peso
para mí fue un momento de muchísima
frustración estrés comparaciones y mucha
desesperación no entendía nada
no entendía nada era el constante
sentirme insuficiente un constante que
estoy haciendo mal porque no puedo
porque no lo logro
yo te digo que estás haciendo humano no
estás haciendo nada mal está creciendo
estás cambiando ya no eres una niña ya
no tienes 14 años y está bien está bien
llegó a tener 14 años lo que no está
bien es que esté formando parte de una
industria en la cual quieran que las
niñas o no acepten que las niñas van a
cambiar y que el proceso natural de una
mujer es que va a cambiar su cuerpo y
que para ellos que son las personas con
la mayor experiencia tú eres la niña tú
eres la nueva la que tiene menos
experiencia la que no sabe nada la más
manipulable y para ellos es mucho más
fácil vender al producto porque
tristemente tú como modelo el producto
suena horrible pero así es pues el
producto para vender
es mucho más fácil usar el producto más
nuevo que seguir intentando usar el
producto que ya gustaron muchas veces
para vender el otro problema aquí es que
la industria utilizan productos con
cuerpo de niña para vender ropa a
mujeres
se dice que hoy en día tengo triste
hacen muchos cambios por ser mucho más
inclusiva lo cual le aplaudo de verdad
espero que eso siga cambiando más sin
embargo tengo a decir como parte de ella
que estamos muy lejos de hacer de esta
realidad serán modos los cambios pero yo
estuve en una de las agencias más
grandes más grandes
y la realidad es que es 12 los casos
pero para el resto sigue siendo la misma
realidad constante de no ser suficiente
de que menos es más de que tienes que
estar con menos yo les puedo decir la
infinidad de comentarios que a mí me
llegaron a hacer
en el momento no me hicieron que pero
que hoy lo hace y que no lo puedo creer
cosas como el hambre es temporal de
acostumbrar cosas
cómete unas almendras de una manzana si
te alambre cosas como solamente trata de
comer sano ya está no se trata solamente
de comer sano se trata de entender que
eres un ser humano diseñado para crecer
y para cambiar
a mí me costó mucho trabajo entenderlo
y para mí
tuve la gran suerte la dicha de siempre
estar acompañada de siempre tener a
alguien a mi lado desde cuando sentía
que el mundo se me iba de las manos
siempre tenía mi familia y gente conmigo
que me ayudaba a suspender pero ver
desde qué quiere gente querida que no
solamente en la cuestión mental pero en
la cuestión física de lg se le estaba
llenando el mundo por las manos se pone
mal es muy triste
yo agradezco que nunca nunca nunca caí
en ningún extremo nunca caí en un
extremo porque para mí mi amor que me
tengo a mí a mi cuerpo y el respeto que
siempre me tuve siempre fue mucho mayor
que el amor que le tenía a dejar de
hacer algo a dejar de comer a dejar de
de hacer algo que porque yo supiera que
me fuera hacer daño fue tal mi nervio mi
estrés y mi presión con este tema
y añadido a esto una pandemia que yo me
estaba acostumbrado a estar tanto tiempo
sola mucho tiempo encerrada
para nadar ataques de ansiedad y añadido
a estos ataques de atracos
si realmente estoy yo para mí han sido
la etapa más difícil de mi vida
estos ataques de ansiedad y de depresión
para mí fueron muy pero muy difíciles a
qué me refiero con ataques de atracones
podía ponerme 2 o 3 a las cenas enteras
en una noche
y cuando dieron dos o tres a las zonas
enteras en una noche me refiero a
literalmente dos o tres a las cenas que
enteras en una noche que al día
siguiente me van a dejar sintiéndome
fatal ya no sólo físicamente porque tu
cuerpo físicamente que la mente no está
hecho para que te coman dos o tres a las
cenas completas sino que ambientalmente
yo me sentía muy mal me sentía incapaz
me alejaba de la de mi familia me da más
pena me esté alejar de mis amigos no
quería ver a nadie me daba vergüenza
hacer yo invitaría mal no quería hacer
nada me quería encerrar en una burbuja y
no salir nunca nunca más
obviamente gracias a esto también empecé
a subir de peso
y para mí era un círculo de no quiero
salir no quiero hacer nada no quiero
trabajar no quiero abundar empecé a
recibir comentarios en redes de esta
niña está subiendo de peso la veo más
gordita la veo más rellenita y para mí
eran de maquillaje tenía muy muy
rebasado yo no quería salir no quería
ser vista prefería esconderme y meterme
hablamos de una voluntad fue hasta mucho
tiempo después como mucho tiempo después
pero se sintió como mucho tiempo después
que dije mariana necesitas ayuda ojo es
muy difícil pedir ayuda porque nosotros
nos sentimos capaces de todos nos
sentimos súper fuertes nos sentimos los
más y es muy difícil aceptar que no
siempre podemos con todo y a mí al menos
se me hizo súper difícil decir mañana
necesitas pedir ayuda y fuera también
puesto es que me pare elige mariana
necesitas ayuda me pare y pedí ayuda
profesional ayuda con expert
fui con un psiquiatra con un psicólogo y
en efecto me diagnosticaron depresión me
diagnosticaron depresión ansiedad y los
pasajes de atracón venían añadidos a
esto porque porque en la parte de mi
cerebro porque la mente
extremadamente poderosa era la manera
del cerebro de meterme el pie porque
sabía que era la manera en la que más me
iba a fregar era la manera en la que más
iba a molestarme a mí misma porque era
la manera en la que yo iba a subir de
peso a nuestra entidad a no sentirme
cómoda con mi cuerpo ya no trabajar que
era lo que yo más quería hacer yo
conjunto en el que yo le hablé a la
gente le dije no quiero trabajar más no
quiero que nadie me vea no me quiero
presentar en los llamados porque me dan
favor que no me cierren los pantalones
el diario misma de verdad que tenía
favor ya no me sentía con ningún talento
ya no me sentía nada me era el favor que
yo le tenía a la ropa al trabajo a todo
hasta que pedí ayuda hasta que encendí
tantas brotan las cosas
la depresión va mucho más allá de sólo
estar triste o de sentirse mal
es muchísimo más de lo que pensamos
vamos a mantener ha de proponerse
colorear mándala es sólo ponerse a
hablar con sus amigos o decirle a
alguien hay una triste aire jade quejar
más mucho pero mucho más allá de eso
igual que los atracones igual con la
ansiedad
yo me yo me acerqué a alguien que me
ayudó y eso fue lo que me empezó a sacar
del aprendiz y con tengo otro los
diagramas ser buenos
tengo irán buenos días son tan buenos
pero aprendí a vivir con los buenos y
con los no tan buenos y aprendí que los
no tan buenos van a salir y que vaya que
bien tengo a los marigliano a ver días
mejores aprendí que no soy sólo una
talla aprendí que no soy solo lo que
opine a un tercero aprendí que no soy
solo como se ve mi cuerpo aprendí que no
son opiniones absurdas de personas
tercera acerca de cómo se ve mi físico
aprendí que son mucho mucho pero mucho
más 10 aprendí que vale muchísimo más
ser la persona auténtica profesional
trabajadora echar para adelante que le
echa ganas que quiere crecer que sea la
persona voluntad guapa mejor vestida con
el mejor cuerpo del lugar
aprendí que yo no es para mucho pero
mucho mucho más que sólo una talla
y muchas cosas más que me llena aprendí
que aprender de otras cosas otras
pasiones que quiero hacer es tirar y
verificar mi carrera le dijo oportunidad
a otras cosas en mi vida me empecé a
caer bien de nuevo empecé a querer de
otra vez beneficiar pasar bien otra vez
el tiempo conmigo misma
aprendí que a veces estos desafíos son
buenos para empezar
a superarte para empezar a aceptar estos
retos que te hacen crecer y que te hacen
más fuertes
un día en pláticas con mi psicóloga y
con el psiquiatra a ellas me dijeron
mariana no siempre necesitas contar todo
a veces hay cosas que tú te puedes
guardar en privado y este tipo de cosas
no siempre las tienes que contar y aquí
estoy yo contando todo y diciéndoles
todo exactamente toda mi vida lo más
roba privado lo más profundo y el mundo
que más me alimento a mi vida lo más
difícil de mi vida y por qué es que
haciendo esto porque creo firmemente que
los problemas se alimentan es siempre el
envío de los involucrados y creo yo que
si no se habla de ellos él solamente
está haciendo un parte de ellos para mí
es mucho más importante hablar de ellos
y demostrarles que yo soy una persona
humana sensible y con sentimientos y no
solamente la persona que viene en redes
sociales producidas maquillada y exitosa
creo que es súper importante que
entendamos que somos seres humanos con
sentimientos que esos sentimientos
siempre van a estar ahí que tenemos que
aprender a vivir con ellos y que tenemos
que enfocarnos en nuestra salud física y
mental y que eso es lo más importante
fuera de nuestro trabajo fuera de lo
demás cualquier otra cosa si nosotros
estamos bien física y mentalmente lo
demás para estar bien siempre
yo he aprendido que si estamos tratando
de vivir bajo la sombra y las opiniones
de los terceros
mientras vamos a encontrar nuestra
felicidad
siempre vamos a estar encontrando
maneras de compararlas
que para mí me dio cuenta mucho mucho
mejor invertido en lo que puedo cambiar
y en lo que puedo mejorar qué es lo que
no depende de mí
gracias